nous sommes avec alfredo arias ancien
haut fonctionnaire à dos du monsieur
ataya ce bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france pourquoi le
conseil de sécurité donc a tenu à cette
réunion qui a été demandée par plusieurs
états non membres du conseil de sécurité
comme le secrétaire général le très bien
dit alors c'est un challenge énorme ce
n'est plus grand challenge que
l'organisation a vu depuis 1945
alors permettez moi de dire comme
senécal a dit il ya deux mille ans
calame et aspire to this occasion ses
locations d'utiliser cette catastrophe
pour préparer un meilleur monde pour
montrer notre courage pour montrer la
solidarité internationale c'est ça que
jenny adam dunn mon ancien collègue en
tant que rapporteur sur la solidarité
internationale et la préparer en
documents déclarations sur la solidarité
internationale que l'assemblée générale
n'a toujours pas adopté
mais michelle bachelet et mon collègue
guerre il est là elle vers la rapporteur
sur le droit à l'alimentation la
rapporteure allen à doha sur les impacts
négatifs de mesures coercitives
unilatérales
ils ont tous parlé de la solidarité
internationale comme la première
absolument
priorité du monde aujourd'hui mais il
faut aussi planifier les mondes
après qu vide il faut mettre à 2 mai sur
en force
de sorte que la charte des nations unies
soit considérée comme la constitution
universel et soient respectés comme tel
alors que les mesures que mon
gouvernement des états unis
les paroles de monsieur temps pas envers
la chine les paroles de cette rampe
envers l'iran les
jésus est là et le cuba et aidera alors
ça me donne vraiment le vertige morale
c'est quelque chose tellement contre lé
droit international et l'ordre
international
ça me préoccupe beaucoup le oui point
que le secrétaire général a présenté au
conseil de sécurité
hier ne suffit pas alors il a même pas
mentionné les mots édition mais s'essaye
à ce jeu je voudrais juste revenir sur
un certain point alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui l'actualité est dominée
par le coroner virus dans le monde mais
pendant ce temps il ya certains pays qui
continuent leur guerre il ya des
conflits toujours en cours je pense
notamment au yémen
ou peut-être un cessez le feu a été
trouvé entre les deux parties comment
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le conseil de
sécurité peut appeler certains pays
justement observé des trêves pour lutter
contre le coronavirus et éviter
d'engendrer un nombre de morts plus
importants alors la coopération est
indispensable
l'organisation mondiale de la santé fait
énormément et les etats unis ne veulent
plus payer alors ce sont des causses
vraiment aberrant alors il faut donner
tout tout le financement nécessaire pour
les organisations des nations unies
qu'il faut ce travail indispensable
maintenant c'est tour jean et quel con
et entend de la part de détrempe il est
proche et avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé ne veut plus payer très bien
en tout cas merci beaucoup monsieur
alfred de zayas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien haut fonctionnaire à l'onu